I'm always making an investment based on
what could the world look like and is
that a world I want to live in the
hardest Investments to make are the ones
that pay off the best it's easy to put
money in when Bitcoins are 67 000 and
it's hard to put money in when bitcoin's
at 15 or 16 000. people say why do you
like decentralized and I say what is
centralized centralized is Putin How do
you decide when you spend Bitcoin versus
when you don't I'm gonna wait for a time
when I I feel that the world understands
it and I think that's probably five
years from now are you still buying
Bitcoin all right guys bang bang I've
got Tim here with me I thought a great
place to start would be uh Innovation is
something that you've hung your hat on
you have an investment style that
benefits when people figure out
Innovation when they're able to build
companies and startups how do you
actually know when something is
innovative versus it looks shiny or
looks sexy but it isn't true really
something that's going to break through
and end up creating economic value so
what's cool about what I do is I can
fail a lot so think of me
swimming really hard and hoping a wave
comes and so when I meet an entrepreneur
where I say oh wow that's really
interesting
um the market size is big enough they're
using technology in a new unique way and
they're talking about the customer a lot
and
if they're successful I like the way
that world looks
then I'm ready to jump in and uh and
about half the time it doesn't work uh
but every once in a while it does and
when it does it usually works bigger
than any of us ever imagined and so
that's why I'm always making an
investment based on what could the world
look like and how is that a world I want
to live in and that turns out to be a
great way to invest yeah when you're
meeting Founders early on
um and you're asking them questions
obviously you're not asking them only
questions about themselves but you're
trying to understand how they think how
they make decisions are there things
that you explicitly look for where
you're like yep that is you know a good
sign or even things that they may say or
do where you're like that's a red flag
I've seen that pattern before and I
don't want to kind of repeat it yeah so
um now all the entrepreneurs who are
listening are gonna game the system but
let me uh I'll give you the hint because
it's you because as it's pop this is you
know very special and I'm just gonna say
I asked the question why are you doing
this and I do it in just that way
because the great entrepreneurs will
rise to the occasion
and the the wannabes or have they'll
sort of say well you know my friend
thought it was a good idea or I wanted
to start a business or whatever I want
to make money or whatever
um we're backing missionaries and it
turns out the mercenaries don't make
money the missionaries do and so the
ones who have it in their head that this
is the way the world is going to look
and this is what I'm going to do and
this is how I'm going to get there and
here's how I'm going to Delight my
customer and this is how customers are
going to become our sales force all
those things then we say okay that's
that's worth jumping into yeah when you
meet some of these Founders what's
always fascinating to me is like Airbnb
goes on to be a massive business
Facebook goes on to be these massive
businesses uh and you hear the origin
stories now there's always the hindsight
bias of like oh we always knew was gonna
be a big business but a lot of times
it's somebody trying to solve a problem
for themselves or for a friend or
whatever and it starts off small how
many of the founders do you think
actually have like world domination as a
kind of vision early on versus they
almost gain confidence as the thing
begins to work more and more and they
realize they can go bigger and bigger
I actually think it is the latter
um at first it's I want to solve this
problem for this customer and I've got
this new technology that is like 10
years better than the technology that
these competitors are operating under
and now I can do something really
interesting for the customer that they
weren't able to do before
well then they jump in and they start
and things start going well and going
well means you've got three customers
who are delighted
uh until you have three customers that
are delighted it's not going well okay
okay before that it's like still failing
um we call that fail and fail again
until you succeed you're still failing
until until you've got three customers
who are delighted and then figure out
how you can make those customers into
your sales force get them
so happy that all they have to do all
they want to do is talk about you and
have them spread it and uh then you
start getting that machine going and
then the entrepreneur can really realize
their full potential their full dream
their full vision and that uh really
does make a difference you you and then
they do start getting
um
big and Broad and thinking bigger and
broader
and they are also capable of doing much
more once your company is profitable all
of a sudden your the world opens up to
you until then you you're at the mercy
of venture capitalists and and like
going into a bear market like this your
Venture Capital should not be your
source of money you need to cut your
team back and make it as efficient as
possible so that you can make it through
and get the money from your customers
when you think of a consumer product
it's very easy to understand what the
problem is Delight three customers they
turn into your sales force you don't
just invest in consumer products you
also invest in all sorts of Innovative
Technologies and so maybe we can use two
examples rockets and Bitcoin which okay
uh a lot of times people like to say
Bitcoin is on the rocket and right going
to the Moon uh but we're going to
separate they're taking a very
circuitous route yes uh it's going up
and down up and down but eventually it
will go up right
um and maybe let's start with rockets
right when you think about some of the
companies that you guys have invested
there how do you think about which
customers are you delighting how do you
think about uh which is the problem a
rocket can do a lot of different things
like walk me through maybe just like
underwriting some of these companies and
use an example or just talk generally so
um it is true that uh Elon when when he
talks about when he talked about Tesla
he was talking about how he could
Delight his customers so he did have
that in mind when
um now backing a rocket company that's
where
that's where the market part comes in to
our thinking the market is nothing's
happened in this industry for years
the the existing parties are not
providing the customer experience we all
want so it had been 50 years since there
had been a successful car company when
we funded Tesla from the very beginning
and uh and and everyone in the world
really thought that Rockets were only a
business for uh for governments and when
you have an industry like that that
hasn't changed forever and you have an
entrepreneur that says huh there's a new
technology here and I can do something
with it and I can jump into this Market
with something that in the case of the
rocket uh was 1 200th of the cost of
what it would take to get a rocket from
NASA so NASA would shoot a rocket up
with a certain payload
um and SpaceX was able to do that for 1
200th of the cost pretty good yeah and
so once you you see something like that
where an industry has gotten sort of fat
and lazy and not to say that the
individuals within NASA are fat and lazy
or the individuals car companies are fat
and lazy yeah they in the car company
example they they they were so caught up
in their own success they they lobbied
government they government sort of wrote
rules to limit what they could do and
then all of a sudden there's this
electric car that comes along that's
that doesn't run like a golf cart but it
runs extraordinarily fast it's a
breakthrough and those breakthroughs
happen occasionally and they are the
hardest to invest in why uh because
well in the case of both of those uh
eight out of the ten Partners at Draper
Fisher germanson uh were saying no
really eight out of ten thought it was a
bad idea and the rest were kind of I
mean and the two of us were pushing
pushing pushing and eventually they sort
of now okay do it but less or whatever
and uh
a little less so with SpaceX because
SpaceX we already knew Elon was capable
of extraordinary things why did you
think that so you guys invested in Tesla
early right and in some ways it's an
insane idea to just go build an American
car company in general right at that
time uh now there's still people who
think it's an insane idea but at least
there's some traction why did you think
Elon Musk was so different than other
entrepreneurs that you all had met well
we backed before we backed Elon we
backed Martin eberhardt in the electric
car business we because
um Tesla was started by Martin Everhart
he uh
it actually started before that I got
this ride
um with Ian Wright who took me on his
right mobile okay and uh and he said
um and I said oh great it's an electric
car this will be like riding in a golf
cart and he he strapped me in with fight
with five point straps and I said what
wait wait what and he and he and I I was
thinking you know you got to be a tree
hugger or a or a golfer to want an
electric car and he said no no stay
strapped in and he took me out on 280
and we went zero to 60 so fast and the
car was sort of held together with PVC
tubing and stuff and um and we're on the
freeway and and I'm just going oh my God
this is amazing you you know this is a
big breakthrough and then he took me
around and he said now watch this and we
were maybe 40 feet from a stop sign
going about 60 miles an hour and he
stopped before the stop sign and I went
oh boy this is a whole different level
in automotive and uh and I and then
there were all these restrictions and
and the Lithium-ion batteries blow up
and all that stuff and then I just
studied the electric car industry I went
out and looked at all the different
um hobbyists who were building electric
cars and they all mentioned Tesla
and the reason they mentioned Tesla was
that he had worked out something where
he could have multiple lithium batteries
and one could blow up and the car would
still go they and and you get more
torque if you run all the batteries at
the same time so
uh then we met with him and it was uh
you know it was a push to get it through
our partnership but then
uh we we got it done and so I um
really do believe that the hardest
Investments to make are the ones that
pay off the best yeah uh and so if you
if it feels like yeah it's hard to put
money like it's easy to put money in
when Bitcoins are 67 000 and it's hard
to put money in when Bitcoins at 15 or
16 000. and uh and that kind of
yeah
you know people call it contrarianism
but I don't think it's exactly
contrarianism because we're actually
trying to catch a wave that's really
important long term
so the one thing that I do do is I
filter out entrepreneurs where where
they're not doing something that I
believe is fundamental or will change
society or will transform Humanity or
we'll do something extraordinary for the
world if and if they're not doing
something like that I um I figured there
are other Venture capitalists who can
back that they can just do it for you
know do it for the money whatever yeah
uh we we end up making more money than
they do but it's just because
we just seem we make more mistakes we
are willing to fail
and uh and when we succeed we succeed
really big and the world changes yeah uh
I'm not an expert on this so you kind of
tell me what what I should know uh
there's a bunch of controversy Elon says
he started Tesla Martin says they
started Tesla whatever uh how do you
kind of just think about like when you
have something that gets really big
there's a lot of people who are like I
was early right you even see this with
employees the whole thing I've met
people who are like I was an early
employee at X company I'm like oh really
like once you join you're like that's
four years after the company started and
you're the thousandth employee and
sometimes it's relative of like if they
have 50 000 being a thousand is really
if they have 1500 maybe it's not so
early how do you think through that and
like does it even matter like I think
maybe it breeds a lot of friends and a
lot of a lot of Founders and
um and then failure everybody runs away
from yes of course and that is a natural
thing and I think I'm a little weird
that way in that
um I'm willing to take unpopular stances
I'm willing to be unpopular for a while
so that then down the road
the world will improve uh if and often
people see that maybe what they're
talking about isn't actually right but
they go ahead and talk about it anyway
and I I think that that's human nature
they don't want to be sort of
left out and and perceived as a failure
they want to be perceived as a success
so they sort of say I'm I attach myself
to this not this the movie business is
very much that way in a way everybody's
a part of you know Star Wars from the
beginning and nobody's a part of Lynn
yendel or whatever you know nobody's a
part of the ones that were bombed the
failures
um and that's that's definitely true in
the Venture business so that does happen
yeah it's a it's a thing and Elon was a
part of the founding of Tesla but he was
Art Martin Eberhard was the original CEO
and that's one way back and then they
ran out of money and Elon said I'll put
in 10 million but I I don't like the way
this is going I've got a better way to
go we were very welcoming to Elon he did
an incredible and he did an incredible
job I mean he he got this huge
government loan 400 million he he bought
the new me plant from from the Ford I
guess for about five cents on the dollar
wow uh he he basically set up for
greatness and he was willing to sort of
lay it all on the line and there were
times when he he had to lend money from
his own pocket to keep the thing going
he had to do so much to make it all work
and he did the same for SpaceX and uh
and really there were times at SpaceX
when things were very tough you know
three rockets in a row blew up
and uh and he still had that faith and
that determination
and uh I think he's probably going to be
able to do that with Twitter too I tend
to think he's going to be okay with
Twitter if you can land rockets and
create an electric vehicle I think
Twitter is the Walk of the Park yeah
well I mean he's it it's gonna he bought
at the top but but uh there will be
another top I think he will be very
successful with that yeah when and I
love how he thinks it's like first I
want to save the planet that's Tesla
well first he wants to create PayPal
which is like anybody can buy things
very easily digitally
then he wants to save the planet with
Tesla then he wants a hedge against this
planet with SpaceX and then he's
thinking we need free speech you know we
seem to be losing free speech and I
think that the pandemic
gave weak government officials the
ability to try to control people
and that was not a healthy thing in fact
I've noticed that in the world that the
weak leaders are the ones who try to
control people and they're strong great
leaders are the ones who trust people
and set them free
and that that is much rarer but the um
the weak ones are like President XI he's
he's decided that he's going to control
1.4 billion people and tell them all
what to do lock them up I mean God and
he's locked up people their houses were
on fire and they had to get out and and
he's his military guys say no you cannot
leave because of this no Zero Tolerance
thing for covet I mean
a a great leader sets people free tells
them everything that he knows and let
lets them figure it out for themselves
and that is a much better way for
um leaders to operate George Washington
he just he said no it's going to be a
free country I'm not going to be the
king of America
I'm going to be the president of America
and after two two terms it's enough
bring on another person
and think of what that did my gosh set
people free for 200 plus years and now
you're seeing weak politicians and weak
leaders and weak government and
employees trying to bring more controls
into the system and I think that's
unhealthy I mean the way I look at it
they people say why do you like
decentralized
and I say okay well
what is centralized start let's start
there
centralized is Putin
with one guy has decided that two he's
going to ruin the lives of 200 million
people just because he decided he didn't
like the idea that he didn't own Ukraine
and all of a sudden he's just ruined 200
million lives that's centralization
decentralization it would be Putin with
you know maybe one or two other people
working on and if they all decide to go
to war then put it put them into a
fighting cage
uh and it doesn't ruin 200 million lives
which is why I love Bitcoin because it's
decentralized
and doesn't have a single point of
failure whereas the FED is centralized
and the FED has its point of failure and
when a government employee a government
um a centralized government decides
they're going to print 10 trillion
dollars
that creates inflation that means your
dollar that used to be worth a dollar is
now worth 82 cents
and then the FED has to make up for it
by saying okay now we got to raise rates
and then you go through this cycle and
people say well what you know why do we
keep going through these Boons and busts
well it's because the the FED has to
react to what the politicians are doing
that's all centralized if it's all run
on bitcoin it's decentralized no one
there are 21 million of them that's all
there will ever be and you and all those
will be run off various nodes and and no
one person can print a whole bunch more
Bitcoin create a crisis in the economy
Force interest rates to go arbitrarily
High uh Force us into a recession so
that people get laid off and then we
have to kind of reinvent ourselves
um so I like decentralization and
centralization is President XI one guy
is just deciding to shut down all of
Shanghai and the entire world supply
chain one guy what's that about when you
think of Bitcoin
I always see the FED as human-led
decision-making that has a variable
policy and is reactive to the world
right so things happen and they react
they raise race they drop race they
whatever
Bitcoin is software so programmatic
monetary policy uh it is not variable
it's set in stone and it doesn't react
when you think of those two systems
they're obviously at odds and going back
to this idea of venture capital uh it's
almost like the perfect Venture Capital
BET right it's like it's definitely
different and if it's right it's super
asymmetric and so obviously uh you were
very early to recognizing that and
wagering quite a bit of money on it
but the counter argument or the critic
would say oh no we need to be reactive
because the FED is able to uh uh cool
off the economy if it gets too hot or
it's able to actually ignite growth when
we get into these bad periods I'm
assuming we see uh similarly kind of uh
why that is wrong but just talk a little
bit as to like how would you tell a
Critic uh of Bitcoin no the programmatic
monetary policy is actually better for
the economy not just for Bitcoin holders
but for the economy to run on this
programmatic monetary policy like how do
you think about that
I think there are a lot of
um people who resist change and they are
um they there are the equivalent of the
the weak leader the one who just wants
it to go the way they want it to go and
they have a job and everything's kind of
going along and they don't want to mess
with it
um I think the the strong people are
accepting of change or even uh embrace
it and they even drive change
and when you have a big change like this
this is an anthropological leap this is
the equivalent leap of going from shells
to gold or gold to the promise of gold
or the from the promise of gold to the
full faith and credit of the U.S
government those leaps brought
um built incredible each one brought
incredible wealth to the world
and each one had people saying no we
still should do shells because that's
the way we do everything and we don't
really want to change anything
uh but then everybody realized that gold
was better and then they moved to the
promise of gold and that was even better
than that and then the credit policy all
of a sudden with credit we were able to
do even more now we have we are making
this this leap
um Bitcoin is is much more liquid
it can move anywhere it it is uh
decentralized transparent it's which
means anybody can see what has happened
on the blockchain everyone can see
what's happened on the blockchain it is
it keeps perfect records
it can be taken anywhere in the world
it's not tied to some political force
that decides that they want like I don't
I don't imagine that the Russians are
taking ukrainees lotties or whatever I
guess polish a lot anyway
um
you you can't buy things with with uh
Fiat currencies that aren't in the
country that you're in unless
they've got a really good relationship
with the other country uh Bitcoins
accepted everywhere and that's a real
benefit long term that's a fantastic
benefit the other part of Bitcoin is if
I need to send money to somebody in
Africa without a bank account
uh I'm not even sure how I could do it I
call my bank they turn them dollars into
something they move it over it has to be
transferred to naira the naira has to
show up and turn into cash and then they
hand it to somebody
that doesn't make for a very liquid
environment but if I have if I want to
send them Bitcoin it's just I'm done and
I've done that actually I bought a bunch
of books from this guy who said I'm
going away for six months to Africa and
I won't have a bank account I said but I
gotta buy the books from you
so I think he made about a million
dollars on those books
now uh I have two questions one one so
there's always that like like you know
Bitcoin is going to be worth more in the
future yes and so you say well do I
really want to spend it but you do want
usage to improve so uh it's always a
trade-off how do you decide when you
spend Bitcoin versus when you don't is
it just this thing is so valuable that
it's worth it or is there some other
framework this episode is brought to you
by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eight sleep pod is the
best sleep machine I sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in eat sleep you can
go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep well I I my
goal is never to sell my Bitcoin but to
eventually spend or invest really I want
to invest it
um and uh but it I'm I'm gonna wait for
a time when I I feel that
that the world understands it and that
the world is um is has finally embraced
it and I think that's
probably five years from now
um
because
uh this is kind of an interesting
statistic
women control 80 percent of retail
spending
and uh and
until recently about 1 in 16 Bitcoin
wallets was owned by a woman
now it's more like one and eight
um
when when at retail when the retailer
can easily accept Bitcoin which they
kind of can now with open node
um they're going to realize that they
can bring another two percent right to
their bottom line
and they're going to encourage their
customers to buy with Bitcoin and the
moment I can buy my food my clothing and
my shelter all in Bitcoin
why do I need a political currency why
would I want a fiat currency
I would just hold on to bitcoin I would
sell all my fiat currency and I think
there will be a moment where there's
kind of a run
on fiat currency where it's like we got
to get out of this is that what you
think basically is like the the end
result here there's a lot of people who
hold Bitcoin some of them have very
extreme views and kind of ultra bullish
some of them are like yeah it's one
percent of my portfolio and you know I
look at it just like anything else your
belief is that Bitcoin will replace Fiat
currencies In Our Lifetime
yeah yeah I I at some point you're not
going to want a government controlled
currency because it does what this
happens you get a boom and then you get
a bust and then the FED has to adjust
um you get and the boom and bust is all
determined by some
political candidate who happened to win
and then they just say okay we're going
to spend a bunch of money
and then you get a boom and then all of
a sudden you you get a huge bust because
the FED has to say wait we're going into
inflationary times we got to raise
interest rates and so all of a sudden
you've got a bust
there's some something healthy about a
boom and a bust but I think you will get
you'll get that anyway
uh people will you know be excited about
something and then less excited and
excited again
I'll give you a kind of interesting
example almost every technology goes
through what I call the the is curve I
even branded it the Draper I asked her
it every industry kind of comes up
um and and then gets hyped to the Max
and then that's sort of the dot on the
eye so the cursive i and then it comes
drops down and they say oh god well this
you know I can't buy anything with my
credit card and I can't do all these
things that the internet has promised I
can't do anything with it and so for
years it sits there languishing but
while it's languishing all these great
Engineers are working really hard and
they're coming up with a great way for
us to experience this internet thing and
then it starts slowly creeping up like
an S and then it uh explodes for years
and then it flattens out as new
technologies come along and go through
their same is curve so it's like almost
like a false start in the beginning like
yeah like there's hype because people
see what it could be but the work hasn't
been done yet so you got to do the work
and then it takes off that's exactly
right so I think the same things
happened with Bitcoin you've
you've had the the big hype eye
and by the way the S is much higher than
the I I mean you think about you know
the top of the eye had Amazon valued at
maybe I don't know 100 million dollars
and now it's worth a couple trillion
yeah two trillion something like that
yeah yeah
um
so that's a thousand times higher than
the I was the s
and so uh people don't even realize how
creative other people are
and they don't realize how big something
like this can become so the internet
transform Communications information
gaming entertainment media
taxis hotels
and those are all pretty big Industries
they're big they have a big influence
and all that
but Bitcoin has a potential Bitcoin with
a blockchain the smart contracts the the
uh eventually doused uh have the
potential to transform the biggest
industries in the world
uh that's all of Commerce
Finance
uh it doesn't just stop with currency
it's
um
you're gonna see major changes in real
estate as companies like property all of
a
sudden
um
uh are the place you go for your title
so you probably wouldn't need title
insurance anymore
insurance is going to go through major
changes and what is government but a lot
of insurance policies and so
um I think government's going to go
through major transformation in fact
I'd say 80 percent of government is
probably insurance it's your health care
insurance your workman's comp your uh
welfare your unemployment unemployment
insurance the pensions and security
Social Security all that stuff
um that probably does make up about 80
percent and so all of that
with a Bitcoin economy could be virtual
and various governments could compete
for your service
to provide better service for you and so
I've seen a few governments that are
being built up in space or 11 miles
offshore or in free trade zones or
whatever and uh take time I'm a
citizen of one of them which one
um oh God I wish I remembered
um he's going to be mad the guy who
created Aragon
is also now created a new government
Luis um
uh cuente he uh and
and anyway he made me the 187th uh
member of the of the government you were
one of the first uh e-residents of uh I
think uh yeah there was supposed to be
number one okay but I ended up being
number three because uh they some New
York Times editor got a chance to be
first in exchange for a story yeah and
then jervinson was second because I felt
like okay Steve you were in a so your
grandfather was the Estonian president
I'll give you number two and then I was
number three okay and um and I really
loved that by the way that government is
so far ahead of our government in in
digitizing the government what are they
doing uh digitized voting digitize the
whole economy is digitized your parking
is digitized your taxes are digitized
Everything is Everything is online
and it's very efficient and that has
allowed that government to uh swing
above its uh weight class it uh it looks
like it's uh I think there may be number
three
as a per capita unicorn Creator wow and
a lot of that is based on a government
that
encourages sets its people free
and trust trust them and sets them free
yeah when we switch from let's call it a
Fiat based world to a Bitcoin based
World however that happens
um or whenever that happens
is it a peaceful transfer or do you
worry that there's like conflict and and
as we've seen over the centuries and
even thousands of years whenever Global
Reserve currencies change hands and
things like that it usually hasn't been
very peaceful how do you kind of think
through that and
um obviously there's an investment case
for an asset but then there's also like
you have family you're a human right
like there's things that like you don't
want to see suffering in the world bad
things so how do you think this plays
out
it is playing out and I I would argue
that we were all pretty much at peace
while the internet was booming because
that was all about Communications and
being better
um you know doing business with each
other and building a supply chain
throughout the world and everybody was
benefiting from that and that was
unprecedented at how how much more
productive people were during that time
and how many people got brought out of
poverty during that time
and then Bitcoin came along
and the great countries the great
leaders are the ones who have embraced
Bitcoin the weak leaders are the ones
who are saying no we've got to control
things and all of a sudden they use that
as an excuse or whatever to show their
true colors which is I need to control
everybody when you have a control-based
government government they go to war
because it's a single person it's a weak
person
it's somebody who gets everybody to do
exactly what they want them to do and
those people also want the rest of the
world to do what they want to do and
they um and so they'll attack if they're
not doing what they want to do so I'd
argue it's already happening
um I wouldn't be surprised if there were
more Wars happening and then when all
the wars are done
um hopefully we'll all serve most of us
will survive or you know vast majority
Will Survive
um that'll be the time when we all kind
of hold hands
the borders start to drop the businesses
start doing doing work across borders
again uh the supply chain reopens up
around the world we don't have to say us
against them and we're all better off
it it feels like
um most people I think in the Bitcoin uh
Community think that is the end State
and there's questions in terms of how we
get there
um but also there's questions about the
U.S government and are they going to
fully embrace it are they going to tax
it are they going to
um maybe in the most extreme case ban
ownership or whatever
it also feels like maybe we've kind of
de-risked some of the most extreme
reactions right we have politicians who
hold the asset uh we have many
businesses that are publicly traded that
uh use the asset many Wall Street firms
now are playing in it what do you think
is kind of the play if you will for the
US government is it something where that
is a fast-growing sector we're going to
put some taxes here and that'll be good
enough or do you think that there's
other regulations that you worry about
or people should be paying attention to
now again I I say that we um the the
good leaders are pushing
they're trusting people and setting them
free and the bad leaders are trying to
control things and regulate and tax and
whatever else now
I understand taxing because it it aligns
interests
and I think that the U.S government
should understand
that they've just wasted a ton of money
on a 80 000 IRS agents where if they
became a Bitcoin economy
everybody be paying their taxes
automatically
and they would they probably could
charge far less taxes because they don't
have to you know have all these guys
going around
wasting people's time you know looking
for frauds looking for whatever because
there would be no frauds uh it would all
be on the blockchain everybody'd see it
everybody knows how much everybody's
making
uh you know I mean the government will
know how much you're making and that tax
will happen
now I actually think you could
experiment with something like a
transfer tax and just put that like
0.0025 or something on all transactions
All Digital transactions and you would
start to see that
taxing Bitcoin as an asset makes no
sense it should be taxed as a it should
be taxed on transactions and then that
would pay for
probably a lot more than what the
government is using it for now and much
more efficiently
um
and I think there's only one or two
countries in the world who have started
to do that
and they are probably going to be
they're going to go from the poorest to
probably some of the wealthiest
countries in the world over the next 40
years because they've done it which ones
uh El Salvador and Central African
Republic and then Malta of course is
going to benefit big
Switzerland is benefiting big because
they're making Bitcoin a part of their
economy
um you think El Salvador will be one of
the richest countries in the world in
the future yeah they're starting as the
poorest Singapore was with one of the
poorest countries in the world 60 years
ago
and Lee Kuan Yew trusted his people and
he he didn't set them free completely he
uh he laid down very clear laws and then
he
then he set them free and he had a
completely free market
and uh and over that 70-year period he
went from poorest to richest
um
if I talked about uh Korea no oh so this
is why I've come to the conclusion about
freedom and trust it's all about freedom
and Trust so they drew this line the
arbitrary line but they split Korea in
half
and the Northerners took on oh and they
drew this line the the
demilitarized zone and that nobody
crossed that line almost zero people
crossed that line over 70 years
so the the North Koreans took on
government control socialism communism
Marxism leninism they took on all those
isms and they um and everybody did what
the government told them to do and the
government told them to do basically
everything their job their everything it
was like government is watching you and
making sure you're doing exactly what
you have to do and that's the deal
South Korea was free market
capitalistic system uh democracy open
borders uh
[Music]
freedom freedom of speech freedom of
whatever trusted their people
okay 70 years have gone by the average
South Korean now makes 460 times what
the average North Korean makes and
that's when adjusted for purchasing
power it's even better uh 460 460 times
and and the average South Korean is now
four inches taller than the average
North Korea that's crazy and that has
been three generations four generations
and suddenly you have entirely different
I mean they're almost different
races yeah of people
and uh and now if even if North Korea
started to create Freedom now it would
take generations for them to understand
the markets and build their base that
Eastern Europe has had that problem too
like
when uh Gorbachev brought down the wall
suddenly the Eastern Europeans said Okay
I want to be a part of this capitalistic
system this thing looks good this thing
looks good but we're not sure we how to
do it and they don't they didn't really
understand the customer and they didn't
there were certain things they didn't
understand on the other hand some of the
best entrepreneurs in the world have
come out of the Eastern block
and that's because the technology
education was so good and they came up
with different ideas they had different
ways of thinking and that kind of thing
so some of that was very healthy yeah
um but that just tells you that
get you want you want more countries you
want more opportunities you want more
choices as a consumer but not just for
all your consumer goods you want more
choices of what government that you want
to work with yeah and those governments
are going to have a variety of I mean
through the
the oh and okay through the Bitcoin and
the blockchain and smart contracts and
Dows you're going to see new governments
jump up that are completely virtual and
you are going to be able to be a part of
them it's like balaji's Network State
idea yeah and I think ultimately the
other land-based governments are going
to become much more efficient
and some of them will fall under their
own weight
what would you do if you're the
president United States you you
understand technology you understand a
lot of the innovations that are
happening you understand Bitcoin and
kind of the potential that it has you
become president tomorrow you get you
know a year Runway you do whatever you
want there there's nobody uh in Congress
or Senate who stops they just say Tim
save us what would you do I think I'd
send that message of we are going to and
to all the government employees to
everybody we're going to trust the
people and we're going to set them free
and uh and those messages will that will
tweak government in so many different
ways
um different things will happen like I
would suspect that that would get
government employees
payments to be not tied the the
improvements in their salary not to be
tied to uh CPI which is what they are
now which is ridiculous it's tied to
inflation but be tied to GDP growth all
of a sudden they're on your side and
it's our government again it's not that
government that's in our way it's our
government I mean we were supposed to be
we the people right now it feels it used
to be that the government worked for the
people and now it feels like the people
are working for the government
um and so I think that that I would try
to get the bureaucracy fired up to
um to
trust the people set them free and and I
would deregulate
massively there are so many regulations
that are overlapping and it's a little
like China they have overlapping
regulations so that they can get you if
you do and get you if they don't it and
and uh so they they just it's their way
of being able to Target people
and I think that's very unhealthy I
think the healthy way to operate is to
say people have to figure out how to
make their living people have to figure
out the way they want to live how they
want to operate in a free market that is
the best system that we've ever had to
do that and it's worked everywhere it's
been tried I think that would be the
approach I would take yeah we've got two
more questions for you the first is uh
are you still buying Bitcoin like you
you bought so much Bitcoin on the on the
auction and people know that story uh
but how do you think about like you have
a dollar do you buy Bitcoin do you save
a dollar do you invest in a startup like
how do you just go through like a
capital allocation decision
great thing great to talk to you about
um I
um I have a big bunch of startups that
are in my portfolio and they need
capital and they
um
if we pay them in Bitcoin if we invest
in Bitcoin
the accountants get three times as much
money
so uh until that is all fixed I will
continue to invest in Fiat yes with Fiat
so
um
uh and I have like I have a fund where I
allow other investors in but it's mostly
well it's not mostly my money it's a
quarter my money
and so I have large Capital calls I have
to make so
as long as I feel that all the capital
calls are covered by Fiat as long as I
feel that I know that I'm going to have
enough Fiat to cover those Capital calls
over this long period of time then the
rest I can put into I can put into
Bitcoin
it's like pretty much you've got
responsibilities and once you know that
the Fiat that you have covers the
responsibilities everything else pretty
much goes in Bitcoin yeah and I have a
foundation that actually has a uh now a
disproportionate amount of Bitcoin
because it I mean we we bought at a
relatively low price and uh now it's
more and so
you you look and say well wait that
isn't a well-managed foundation well
actually it's really well man
uh track record says otherwise
um my last question for you is uh right
now there's investors there's Founders
that are all going through uh this like
recessionary period And I know that now
somehow we're debating what is a
recession was not a recession whatever
it's worse times than it was a year
right right uh and there are people who
are debating whether it will get worse
than it is now or maybe it'll get better
but how do you over the years kind of
think about these periods what do you do
what do you give advice to Founders to
do like just how do you navigate a
recession if you're a tech investor a
founder or somebody who's into Bitcoin
so I was lucky because I've already been
through this with a.com boom and bust
and
um and during the boom people were
losing their minds and their pets.com
and whatever else and it was like uh
this guy I knew it was the top of the
market although I I didn't know
the guy came to me and he said yeah I'm
a rocket scientist and I'm doing
hotels.com
and I thought what
you were not meant to be doing
hotels.com you're meant to be a rocket
scientist and uh and I started to think
oh I get it there's there's something
that this sort of you know the greed
thing has taken over and people aren't
doing things for the right reasons
but then I saw it all disappear very
quickly and that was even quicker than
what you're seeing here
and uh and so then I got to see what
happened afterwards and so since I saw
that I saw it again here with um with a
big boom in the tech stock market and I
was telling
um all my entrepreneurs because these
guys tiger Global and all these big huge
uh Adventure hedge funds were coming in
with huge amounts of money and I thought
wow this is very unusual and so I told
all my entrepreneurs two years ago
just
raise as much as you can don't spend it
raise as much as you can don't spend it
now some of them listen some of them
didn't ones who didn't are now in a
tough spot
we now tell them
you've got to cut your business down you
got to cut your team down you know keep
growing your business but cut your team
down
and I remember it with a.com bust I went
to a company and I said okay so how many
people do you have and they said 400.
and I said okay you got to cut that to
three and they said 300 and I said no
three people wow and I looked and I said
you have to start getting your money
from customers you the Venture Money's
been too easy
and it's not going to be there anymore
and so you got to get your money from
customers and they went out of business
yeah
um because they didn't do any of that
they thought I was just out of my mind
which you know is arguable you know go
ahead think about it
listen to me long enough and you'll go
yes he is completely out but I think
what I think is interesting there though
is like it's almost
um uh the propensity for action or like
a violence of action of from 400 to 3.
obviously okay 400 to 300 400 to 200 400
100 even crazy let's do 450 but 400 to 3
there's like a sticker shock to that
but really what I taking away from that
is like sometimes that is what is
necessary it depends on the situation
but like that could be what is necessary
yeah I think sometimes you have to do
you're running a business you've got
let's say you've got 10 million dollars
in the bank
and you're burning
a million a month
okay 10 million in the bank you're
burning a million a month you're done in
10 months
okay a bear Market can be I mean the
the.com bear Market that was eight years
seven six or six eight years more than a
long time
and if you aren't figuring out how to
get get money from customers before that
you're gonna be out of business
and uh
in fact there's a group correlation
Ventures who who
said uh to me that there is almost it's
almost bifurcated that if a company
is and this is before the big bull
market if a company is spending more
than three hundred thousand dollars in a
month the odds of their success go down
like
like a waterfall wow and the the odds of
success is somebody who's burning less
than three hundred thousand are much
better and it's almost that's the number
just keep it down below 300 000 a month
and you have a pretty good shot at
making it because
even in a bear Market The Venture guys
can dig deep and maybe put some money in
to keep you alive if
um if that's the burn rate but if the
burn rates a million a month 10 10
million a month in some cases what's the
worst you've ever seen what's the worst
burn rate that's probably in the 10
million a month 10 million dollars a
month somebody was burning yeah is it a
publicly known company or is like a
no-name company oh I I mean I've seen
that kind of thing recently a lot yeah
but I think now you not going to be
you're not going to see that
10 mil I mean and for those so I think
you've got to run your business
conservatively
in that way is don't run out of money
it's shocking out of money it's over
yeah it's done your whole dream your
vision is done
and if you do run out of money if if you
don't run out of money there's still a
good shot you can make it so just
manage it tightly don't run out don't
run out of money and check out Bitcoin I
think that's a great I think that's a
great summary of our conversation where
can we send people uh you've got book uh
you're online where do you want us to
send people so um you can follow me on
Twitter
um uh the uh
you can uh pitch us draper.vc
um you can uh you can watch our show we
have a show called meet the Drapers
where we have fantastic guest judges and
it was started as just a whim between me
and my dad and my sister and we just
started this thing and my my kids and we
started this thing we wanted to
interview entrepreneurs on online and
um here we have we have 11 million
viewers now in our next season season
six looks like it's going to be 30
million viewers I I can't believe it
we've we I can't believe that many
people want to watch but it is sort of
fascinating to watch these entrepreneurs
going through what they're going through
we interview them we ask him very
different questions it's very it's a
different show than like a shark tanker
where
um and we're uh we're really excited
about that and then if if you are like
somewhere around 25 years old and you're
thinking I want to go do something with
my life and I have great passion and I
kind of have an idea
then think about going to Draper
University applying to Draper University
that's another of our things and you can
read my book which is
it's fun uh just Google your name and
they'll find it they'll find all sorts
of things they're going to find things
that don't even want to say
things you can't unsee
all right Tim well listen thank you so
much for doing this and we're definitely
do it again in the future thanks for
having me on the show